[Music]
he
if you visit Jerusalem or even if you
see a picture of Jerusalem probably the
most prominent and recognizable
structure is the Dome of the Rock on the
Temple Mount this Islamic Shrine looks
absolutely amazing and that's not
surprising since the architecture was
copied from the byzantines the octagonal
shape was copied from the church Church
of the seat of Mary which was once
located just outside of Jerusalem the
Dome was copied from the Church of the
Holy Seiler The Architects deserve a lot
of respect for copying the perfect
collection of features to make this
Shrine a work of art The Rock in
question is the foundation stone
sometimes called the noble rock rocks
are very important in Islam many Jews
and Muslims and Christians believe that
the foundation stone was the location of
the holy of holies in the second Jewish
temple during the time of Jesus and that
it was where the Ark of the Covenant was
placed in Solomon's
Temple most people don't know that
there's a chamber underneath the
foundation stone called The Well of
Souls which may have been an ancient
hiding place for the Ark of the Covenant
now for some history as I mentioned the
Dome of the Rock probably stands on what
used to be the site of the second Jewish
temple rebuilt by Herod the Great which
was the Heart of Worship for Jews
herod's Temple was destroyed by the
Romans in ad70 following the baroka
Revolt in the 2 Century the Romans built
a sanctuary for their God Jupiter on the
Temple Mount but the Romans eventually
converted to Christianity so from the
4th Century to the early 7th Century
Jerusalem was controlled by the
byzantines Jerusalem quickly became a
popular religious pilgrimage site for
Christians but in 638 the city was
conquered by Muhammad's companion caleff
Umar several decades later construction
of the Dome of the Rock began during the
umad cipate on orders of the caleff
Abdul Malik now why did Abdul Malik
build the Dome of the Rock most Muslims
are convinced that it was to honor
Muhammad's night Journey when the
prophet of Islam was taken to the Temple
mount on a mythical flying donkey
monster named Barack but there's no
evidence that Abdul Malik built the Dome
of the Rock to honor the night Journey
the night Journey was apparently a later
Legend lots of Muslim Muslims are
convinced that Surah 17 verse1 of the
Quran refers to the night Journey the
verse says exalted is he who took his
servant and in Brackets the translators
add I.E Prophet Muhammad By Night from
al-masjid alh Haram to al-masjid Al AA
whose surroundings we have blessed to
show him of our signs indeed he is the
hearing the seeing notice there's
nothing about a flying donkey taking
Muhammad to Jerusalem Jerusalem isn't
even mentioned later Muslims identified
al-masjid Al AA as the Temple Mount but
this verse doesn't say any of that
indeed the verse doesn't even mention
Muhammad that was added by translators
watch what happens when we take out the
part the translators added and we
include the very next verse for
context exalted is he who took his
servant By Night from al-masjid Al Haram
to al-masjid al- a
whose surroundings we have blessed to
show him of our signs indeed he is the
hearing the seeing and we gave Moses the
scripture and made it a guidance for the
children of Israel that you not take
other than me as a disposer of Affairs
in context the night journey in the
Quran sounds like it's talking about
Moses God took Moses from one place to
another place and gave him the scripture
to guide the children of Israel later
Muslim sources claimed that this is
about Muhammad's night Journey but this
later Legend had nothing to do with
Abdul Malik building the Dome of the
Rock The Dome of the Rock was built
before the story of Muhammad's night
Journey was invented how do we know well
the Muslims who constructed the Dome of
the Rock in the 7th Century included
inscriptions verses of the Quran that
show what their intentions were and the
inscriptions are about Jesus the verses
are a rebuke to Christians and to Jews
the inscriptions Proclaim that God has
no son and no partner that's a response
to Christians but they also Proclaim
that Jesus is a prophet from God that's
a response to Jews on a side note the
quranic inscriptions contain textual
variance from the Quran Muslims read
today which means that we can also think
of the Dome of the Rock as a reminder
that the Quran has not been perfectly
preserved so Abdul Malik seems to have
built the Dome of the Rock as an insult
to Jews and Christians rather than as a
memorial to Muhammad's night Journey the
night journey and Surah 17 aren't even
mentioned but the story of the night
Journey became popular later in the sir
and the Hadith and so the Dome of the
Rock was retcon as Islam's thirdd
holiest site because of its connection
to Muhammad's imaginary flight to Mecca
and Ascension to heaven the Dome of the
Rock was damaged by earthquakes in 808
and 846 the original Dome collapsed in
10:15 and was rebuilt several years
later in 1099 following years of
persecution against Christian pilgrims
and even the destruction of the Church
of the Holy Seiler considered by many to
be Christianity's holiest sight
Crusaders attacked and conquered
Jerusalem they turned the Dome of the
Rock into a church and the neighboring
mosque the al- AA mosque soon became the
headquarters for the Knights Templar
Jerusalem was reconquered by Muslim
Muslims in 1187 and the Dome of the Rock
was reconsecrated as a Muslim
Shrine over the centuries the Dome of
the Rock went through various
Renovations and Restorations including
the beautiful tiles on the outside some
of which look like pictures of demons
and of course the gold plating on the
dome which was added in the 20th century
and now after being built and rebuilt
after changing hands repeatedly the Dome
of the Rock stands as a perfect Shrine
for Islam the architecture was copied
like Muhammad copied almost everything
in his religion the location was chosen
specifically because it was a holy site
for other people just like the cabba was
once a center of pagan worship and as
the Hagia Sophia was a center of
Christian worship and as the babri
Masjid was built on what Hindus believe
to be the birthplace of Rah Islam is
obsessed with controlling other people's
holy sights just as Muhammad was
religious figures turning Abraham and
Moses and David and Jesus into devout
Muslims toss in a bunch of later myths
and legends and embellishments and
convince hundreds of millions of people
that they absolutely must preserve this
slap in the face to Jews and Christians
everywhere and you get the ultimate
Monument to everything history's most
obvious false prophet came to
[Music]
do
he